New Year
yes according to the display
but let's let's start anyway
so our next talk is uh
by Alex guerrillo from
see
cnfs
and he will talk about Quantum learning
algorithms and how they imply circuit
lower bounds
for an organizer setting up this
wonderful workshop and yeah these are
going to work with scene vazen who's
also here uh tongur Igor who's
organizing the workshop and R key
and um
I'm a Quantum person so we're starting
like uh like we try to somehow find a
good Quantum algorithms and people
I have done it for some problems for
example know how to uh so factor in our
discrete log much more efficient like
polynomial in polynomial time and the
classical don't know how to do that we
know how to add some speedups
um and then people start thinking okay
let's try to do it for something that we
can actually
it will have a lot of impact in
everyday's life so for example can you
can reduce to solve machine learning or
promote complexity Theory perspective
the quantum learning theory
and we people think that this uh gives
us a great potential to to explore
Quantum power to achieve this but we
don't have too many uh provable results
on these so there are a lot of
heuristics there there are a few
examples or know how to achieve Quantum
speed ups but um not as exciting as uh
we would think
and uh this talk is somehow an
explanation why we don't to have too
many uh provable results on Quantum
learning theory is because if you what
you show is actually if you improve from
any uh if you have any improvement from
trivial Quantum learning then you can
actually improve circular bonds and
Achieve breakthroughs in complexity
so our result uh it's like yeah it lies
in this intersection between learning
theory Quantum algorithms and complexity
Theory
I expect people but are more familiar
with the complexity theory part I won't
go too deep in Quantum so it should be
fine like it should be a black box thing
but if you have any questions like
please stop me
and uh yeah we'll connect them with
learning theory and please uh yeah ask
questions I think it'd be good to be as
interactive as possible
um just to I think most of people here
know about this but okay in the 80s we
we had this uh proving circular amounts
was a thing so we had a
impressive results showing that party
was nothing I see Zero we we showed that
like even with for example multi Gates
we
um we can prove a strong lower bounds
and okay as far as I was I was getting
bored somewhere here so but the the the
the feeling that I have that's okay we
thought that inverse and B was almost
there right we were getting there soon
but then in the 90s oops and 2000 sounds
okay we saw okay not really that like
[Music]
very nice results but then like we got
stuck
and uh we still believe that okay we can
prove circular bombs right we still
believe that NP cannot be solved with
polynomial size circuits but even today
we don't know how to do it for next
right which is much much uh bigger than
NP
and uh then uh like as I said like in
the 90s and eight in the early 2000s we
didn't know how to solve thing like new
techniques to to reach circular bounds
but then uh Ryan came with this a nice
connection between uh algorithms for
solving some problems and proving
circular bonds and through this
connection uh he could show for example
that you cannot uh solve all problems in
X with acc0 circuits
and uh the main idea of our work is
somehow leave this connection between
algorithms and circular bounds to the
quantum setting
and
when we have seen that the quantum
algorithms are more powerful right the
generalized cluster algorithms so in
some sense we have more chances of
finding circular amounts by trying to
find these Quantum algorithms
um we show okay uh yeah I'll say it
tomorrow's life but the circuits are
classical but we show that a Quantum
class is not in it
any more questions
so let me explain a bit what's the
learning model that we use here
and it's some sort of the the quantum
pack model but we with a few with a few
differences so again as in the back
learning we have a family of functions
our concept classes see but then you
have one of these Concepts F that you
want to learn and these concept a
specific concept of course is unknown
and what we want is to have this
learning algorithm for this uh for
learning this concept class C and uh in
our model we give Oracle access Quantum
Oracle access to the uh to this to the
circuit and this is just uh
Quantum things need to be unitary
reversible so you need to to define the
article in a different way but this is
you can see this is a just Oracle axis
to a function
and uh at the end like after making
queries to to this article and uh doing
some competition our goal is that what
we want to say this outward we want to
put a new internet new that approximates
uh F and I knew it is just like you can
take it as just a Quantum algorithm
and by that we mean that okay you have
this Quantum algorithm you give some
input X
for Quantum we need to give some Ancilla
qubits uh to the algorithm to run and
what you want is that if you measure one
of the skill bits you have the right
answer which will get at least one minus
that form
and as in the popular settings we wonder
okay this you should have this uh you
should output these Quantum hypothesis U
with high probability over the
randomness of a
okay so this is some sort of the quantum
pack learning but the only difference is
that now you have um this Quantum
hypothesis instead of a classical
hypotenuse
okay with the respect to the uniform
distribution yeah yeah let's say oh no
no here sorry you have a Oracle access
so it can do whatever Oh you mean the X
here I don't know yeah according let's
say according to the apron
yeah yeah
so yeah
you don't know yeah I'm just I mean just
for the base states but uh
other questions
foreign
first of all usually we don't we usually
study Quantum samples instead of quantum
query access
and also I think for the best of our
knowledge we're the first ones to Define
somehow Quantum hypothesis so we usually
what do larger Theory you have a
controller in algorithm that's a
classical hypothesis so this is the
first time that we somehow generalize
that
but I I'd like that this is good in our
case because we want to find more
expresses models so so
having these two relaxations is actually
somehow easier to find Quantum
algorithms which in our case is better
because then it's easier to find like to
prove these circular amounts and like
easy
like not harder not not that this is
okay
so a bit more now in details of what we
prove
what to show is that if you have uh a
circuit class or a concept class C that
can be learned with error Epsilon which
is uh smaller than half minus gamma
uh on time that's little of gum Square 2
to the N uh over n
then we show that uh there are problems
in BQE which is quantum exponential time
uh that cannot be solved in uh with
circuits of uh privacy
okay so yeah this is your question so
this class of circuits will be classical
but now we show that BQE like Quantum
exponential time is not and
okay and I'd like like there's this
uh this is unconditional
okay the condition is that you can learn
it right so like if you can learn if you
have this kind of learning algorithm
then then you you can prove the circular
bounds
but what if the BQE obqe
and one thing is that okay yeah this is
for every gamma so there is a trade-off
that you can choose okay you can have uh
some error that's close to half but then
you pay here on the running time or vice
versa and actually it's interesting
because it touches two uh to trivial
learning algorithms
so the first trivial learning algorithm
is just let's query all the all the all
the inputs
who learn the truth table and here I
give you an exponential size circuit
that solves the function right that that
sorry that uh outputs the right value
and this takes exploration time and zero
error
right this okay but this is algorithm is
actually classical there's nothing new
here but what's interesting with Quantum
is that there is a second type of trivia
algorithms which is Fourier sampling
and this is just uh with Quantum we can
do for the assembly Just Fishing one of
these Fourier coefficients uh important
number of time and what we can show that
this four here coefficient will have a
non-trivial uh correlation with your
function so you you can find another
another trivial argument that works for
every possible function that runs in
time polynomial and Achieve uh some
error that is half minus
um to the minus to n over two okay you
have a quadratic speed up over a random
gas
and if you compare this type of these
two types of trivial Learners with our
result is that actually this what this
result is say is that if you have any
improvement over this two type of
trivial Learners then you can actually
prove the circular amounts
so this is I think the the punch line so
finding non-trivial controller learning
algorithms should be hard
police like like can you match can you
match the
yeah
we have a trivial learner that's in
between the two yeah
I I don't think so
whether for every gamma you can get
something very close to this but not let
alone
some elements
then when you try to learn these
elements you you answer the correct one
otherwise you and you also do something
otherwise you'll do the other this could
work I've never worked out this the math
but it is
asking if this is the theorem that we
should expect to see right whether
all you know is you have to match these
two things in the extreme cases yeah
no but uh no no actually
you're not matching that right if you
put this parameters here we don't have a
circular ball because this works for
every function
right but you want the theorem you want
the theorem to say if you beat the if
you're not trivial
then then you get a you get a lower
bound to the questions so yeah you mean
that trigger could be actually not these
two ones but there is a continue between
events yeah okay
so the other things you can do
because
oh so yeah this is one of the open
questions yeah can you use it to
actually like our result is going in
this tool the question is let's use
we don't know but even for places where
you know certain people are done
um in the current okay
in the samples models we do in the queer
model we're not sure maybe
I don't think we know
oh okay yeah I'm
there there's a loss in the parameters I
didn't put to not like yeah I didn't put
all the details I think here
[Music]
um
the size of the circuits that you're
learning and the size of the circuits
that you you provide somehow there is a
loss in the parameters it's not too big
but there is someone else there
sorry I'm assuming that you had gadgets
like the circuiting increases right yeah
the classical version there's no loss at
all
like for like that two threshold
circuits and this works
but I think no but the loss is in the
size so for us not only that
I think there wasn't size up so what
happens
yeah
no it's just less size yeah
okay so yeah we can sit in two ways so
either we have a new approach to prove
circular bombs or just that yeah having
fun to learn and algorithm is hard so
cool we're trying to work
uh now let me
um my goal now is to give an idea of the
proof
um
and the first step is to show that uh if
you have Quantum learning algorithms
this implies something I've defined as a
control generalization of natural
properties
uh and morally they say that okay if you
can learn the safety plus they can
distinguish the truth table of functions
of functions in the circuit class from
random functions this is uh this is what
this bullet is saying
uh then uh it comes I think the
technically one of the like the the main
technical result is showing that uh if
you we show that if P space is hard by
you know Define later what heart means
then we can show that there exists up
here again that Foods uniform Quantum
circuits
and uh the technical tools that we use
uh for that is having like fish based
like using the piece based complete
problems that are self-reducible
uh use hardware simplification and uh
how to build prgs from hype functions
but then we have to consider everything
in the quantum setting so we have to uh
as our talking a bit we have to to show
that how this reconstructions and how
these reductions they also work in the
quantum setting
uh and finally when we have these two uh
these two results we use a winning
argument
uh in which we say that okay if P space
is easy then there are simple ways of
finding circular bounds and this is
somehow comes from the classical setting
from Raul and um Igor
otherwise if P space is hard we then use
the prg and the Continental property
that we have in order to to hit a hard
function
okay so this is yeah this is the big
roadmap of how our proof works and now
I'll highlight a few of these uh
elements
uh any questions
so
um so if not I'll start with bullet
tools I'll start a bit how can you
somehow build the spirit juice
and let me just State uh the theorem
attribute we show that okay if P space
is nothing we could beat your time to
the end to the gamma for some gamma
then you can find these uh create this
studio run on generators GN uh that
stretches uh from uh strings uh of size
m to the alpha two strings n to the two
to the end to to Lambda
uh we need this okay what we can show is
that these secrets they can be computed
in time two to the end to the alpha
and finally the we show that yeah this
is secure against uniform Quantum
computation so if you have a uniform
family of quantum circuits then this is
the random meaning that you you cannot
distinguish uh from the output of the
the children generator and a truly
random value okay so this is a standard
definition with uh with this probability
with disadvantage
so this is uh what we're able to show
and uh
we we actually so our result we
reconstruct such a prg assuming this
space uh the hardness of the space
and the construction is as follows so we
start with our Assumption of course that
the space is not paying bigger time to
the end to the uh to the gamma
and uh from that of course then you can
uh have a find this nicely space hard
function f and nice is just uh being
self-redustible
um
then you if you pick this hard function
f you can just go uh compute the the
derivation direct product of this
function f to the k
uh apply the go to Hash living on this
uh this parallel petition or this direct
product of of the function and finally
uh use this uh this function on a Nissan
victorson generator
and what to show is that okay if you
have a distinguisher
a Quantum distinguisher with some
Advantage gamma here then you can
actually uh use it like we proved that
okay a Quantum version of Nissan bigger
song that given the distinguisher you
can actually uh
compute this function f to Decay uh
inner product r with uh with Advantage
hat plus gamma
from that we can uh prove okay this was
already proven actually before that from
that you can prove some sort of
reconstruction algorithm that gives up
an algorithm that computes F to Decay uh
on on arbitrary inputs with uh with uh
with priority at least gamma cubed over
two
from that you would do a Quantum version
of ijkw that shows that from this
algorithm B you can find another another
hour that now computes F on uh a big
chunk of the inputs
and finally from that we can uh
uh compute the the p-space hard function
uh F but we know that uh with
hyperability but that will for every
input X but we know that this should not
be possible by by our assumption so we
know that this is travel through so we
find this contradiction here and um
and uh this proves that uh that uh this
construction is a good Southern
generator against uniform content
distributes
and uh the main technical point that we
need to to show is how like this uh so
I'd like to highlight a bit how why why
it's hard to put in a Quantum setting
and uh the idea here the the question
here is how to uh from this uh algorithm
that solves F uh the direct uh product
of f to on some uh or on a fraction of
the inputs how to bootstrap that to have
an algorithm C that computes F on a big
chunk of of labels I think this is the
main uh the main technical result and
I'd like to highlight a few points on
that
okay any questions about the
construction
advice or something that's why you're
saying this direct product thing is like
no no it's All Uniform no advice
would it be easier
uh yeah it should be no harder but uh
then we would not be able to use it uh
because then at the end of the day we
will have uh we wouldn't have anything
from certain classes
so yeah one question I mean why isn't it
enough to at least so these are all sort
of these classical results for hardness
amplifications your Randomness which all
red wise on the right right so if you
have a hardness against a circuit Class
C then if you also have hardness against
C with an a Oracle then everything works
for the aortic group why can't you just
choose like bqp oracles and get
everything to work uh okay maybe okay
I'll explain to us next slide and then
if there are any questions are I think
then uh you can ask them
uh for those who have never seen ajkw I
think this is a very formal way and very
specific like they differ something much
more General but something that I like
commented or some corollary of their
results the following
this completely classical if there is a
if you have function f
such that no BP time uh T algorithm can
compute F on more than one minus Delta
fraction of the inputs then what they
show is that
uh no bigger time t to the one over C uh
algorithm can compute F to decay
on Martin e to the minus uh uh Delta K
Over C fraction of the input so you see
that uh
this is saying that if f is somewhat
hard
after the K will be much harder okay
this is what they're they're saying and
they prove this by somehow a
reconstruction algorithm they show that
if there is an algorithm that computes F
to Decay then you can compute F uh
modern distraction of the inputs then
you can reconstruct F sorry construct an
algorithm for f that learns uh sorry
that computes you can can create an
algorithm that computes F on more than
one minus a fraction of the inputs okay
this is
some interpretation of the result
and one question is why is it hard to
quantize it like why why it's not so
simple to to do it and I think the main
point is that classically you can pull
out Randomness and quantly you cannot
pull out quantines okay so if you have a
randomized algorithm you can fix the
randomness and sorry you can pick the
randomness and then run a deterministic
algorithm and quantly this is not
possible at all yeah
3K in every seat or no no there's some
trips this Universal sea such that for
every k
is it like that oh okay all right
other questions
yeah
um
and why is this important to pull out
Readiness I I think one of the most
important parts is that once you fix the
randomness somehow when when you have
these algorithm that works for some of
the inputs uh we can partition Naples on
the good ones that the algorithm will
answer correctly and the bad ones which
are the the inputs that they always move
on correctly
and things with Quantum you cannot uh
really somehow pull out quantones we can
have to partition well these inputs and
this
creates a lot of uh mess and then uh
is not so simple so our approach is to
somehow actually improve some a bit more
General it's not not just about Quantum
algorithms we show that how to do this
type of uh statements for what you call
inherently randomized algorithms which
are just randomized algorithm that you
cannot pull out the randomness so it's
just a box which which you give an input
and it gives a randomized output and you
cannot control like it's Randomness so
so and and then you want still to to
achieve the same type of uh of uh of
statement okay and Quantum algorithms
are this type so is that slightly more
General uh result than just proving it
for Quantum algorithms
and it turns out that
morally
algorithm that you use is exactly the
same as uh jkw
uh so morally the idea is why jkw works
are the same here but technically that
there is but it's much more subtle and
we need to develop uh
busy it's more okay at least for me it's
more of a technical contribution than um
I don't know conceptual one because it's
just using their you know their
intuition but but then you have to work
harder to achieve the same result
okay so any questions
okay
so what will be the result in the end
the same thing about this Quantum yeah
it's likely worse parameters I don't
remember the requirements but um roughly
the same result
okay so this is yeah to so
to finish a bit uh like to tell a bit
more about this the construction of prg
um if this is fine then we'll switch to
gears and uh talk about Quantum natural
properties
and uh yeah as you might know uh natural
property uh denatural property against
some cerebral Class C sorry a property p
is a denatural property against circuit
Class C
first of all if given a truth table of
uh some function f
uh in um in this in this property
you can decide sorry giving a truth
table or function you can decide if it
has the property or not in uh in this uh
Class B
uh we have that for a random function it
will have the property Authority at Mo
at least half
uh and for every function that is uh in
this uh security class then actually it
does not have the property
uh and uh yeah our another contribution
that we did is okay have some sort of
yeah the first way uh I think the first
time that uh we have seen it is uh
having this Quantum version of it
and we call that this properties bqp
promise uh natural property and it's
morally the same thing but now with
Quantum algorithms so uh we know that uh
there there is a Quantum algorithm D
that runs in uh Quantum polynomial time
sorry in polynomial on the truth table
of the of the function and can decide if
if the function has the has a property
or not
uh we needed to deal a bit like these
Quantum algorithms they are inherited to
randomized so we want that for
a large test subset of all the functions
uh we have that this algorithm will
accept it with very high probability
with Verge that's exponentially close to
one
and finally for functions that are in
the class the algorithms should uh not
accept which probability uh except with
a probability exponentially small okay
so this is
a technical but it's just like a
straightforward definition of quantum
natural properties from from the
classical ones
uh then uh we extended some sort of this
classical results that uh we have point
to learning algorithms implies uh
Quantum natural properties
and uh the the main idea is that if you
have a Quantum learning algorithm then
you can somehow uh distinguish you can
see another say another way of seeing
natural properties is a distinction
between random and uh structure right
and the ideas that they learn in
algorithm the the the the the natural
property will just somehow try to learn
this function from the truth table
uh and then we test to see if you learn
it correctly or not if you learn it
correctly then it's a you know that uh
it is in a circular class otherwise it
should be random so so this is the
intuition of how to get a natural
property out of uh learning a learning
algorithm
and we can show that okay if you pick
the parameters correctly then uh it has
exactly the properties that you want
uh and finally we finish uh the proof by
showing like a finally showing that if
you have this quaternal properties that
come from this Quantum learning
algorithms we can uh prove the circuit
lower bounds
uh and we show that by saying okay if
you have a bqp if you have these Quantum
natural properties for the safety class
you there are two cases that can happen
so first is that there is a language in
BQE
that uh cannot be computed by Boolean
service of size n to decay
or we show that the uh
sorry yeah
so we show sorry and and show that if
there exists a natural property so here
we use the natural property uh
assumption then you can show that e is
not in this uh in this circular uh uh
with these parameter so this is the loss
I think your question so the loss that
we have is uh somehow it's here like we
we have this secret uh the not the
natural properties I guess and today uh
the circuit of size n today but then you
show the circular balance of of the
circuits of size n to the eight over V
um
and the proof of this statement is
um closely like it's almost the same of
this result by Olivia and Santana uh
and the idea is that if you know that P
space is easy then we can find uh some
language empty space that cannot be
computed by by these Boolean circuits of
size and to decay
and uh if mistakes is hard then the idea
is that to use the prg against uh that
that to construct from the Assumption uh
and the natural property that you have
from assumption uh to to find a hard
function that's not in this circuit uh
in the circuit class
and let me zoom in a bit in this last uh
this is last slide I'm sorry in this
last bullet
um
the idea that you have all the functions
and if you haven't Continental property
we know that uh there's a big part of
this uh or the functions that are in
this uh pretty much of one of the
Contour natural property this from the
largest uh assumption
and we know that uh there is this
smaller chunk that is uh is in the
Pyramid of 0 of this quadrature property
and we know for sure that this circuit
class is
independent of zero right this is from
the usefulness of the Continental
property
and then what what to do is to use the
material generators to somehow uh
uh to create uh two Stables of functions
and we know that since this is uh to the
random we have that some of these uh
some of these uh outputs of these uh of
these children generators will fall in
the premage of uh of one of the
Continental property and therefore we
have hit the the heart function
so this is the intuition
um
and uh this is what I just said so you
have the children generator and you see
its output as a truth table of functions
and since we know that uh it's to the
random against uniform control circuits
then we can they are distinguishable
from truly random functions
and therefore there must exists one of
these inputs to the prg such that the
truth table of the the sorry that when
you see the the output of the prg on
this input as a function then we know
that it is not in the circuit class
but then the problem is how can you find
such a certain input because this
somehow we have this sort of stable but
it somehow depends on this X
uh but the point is you don't need to
really find these acts like we don't
need any advice to do that because we
can define a language that given the
input X and some value I it outputs G of
x uh on I like the direct bit of G of X
so this is how sorry the language is uh
X and I such that g uh when you consider
the ice bit of GX this should be equal
to one
and we can show that uh this uh this
language easily and it comes from uh the
time that we need to run a prg
but uh it is not in in C because we know
that uh
because if if it was in C then uh when
you consider FN Gen X starn then it
should be in C as well by restriction so
uh from these two statements you have
this language that is in e but not in
the circuit Class C
shh
um I'd like to now just to finish some
of them problems so yeah the first one
is okay we have this connection between
Quantum algorithms and circular bounds
uh can we use it so can we really find
algorithms that will give us a new
circular Mouse
um also I think our results somehow
everything is very modular so the idea
is that if you have better prgs then you
could also give better uh circular
bounds just in the parameter so this
will be a technical uh Improvement on
our result how to uh somehow connect a
bit more the the parameters of the
learning algorithm and the circular
bounds and I think also there is this
hardness amplification in the quantum
setting or the inherent uh randomized
setting and I it might find other
applications
um in Quantum I don't know Quantum
complexity Theory and I think it's an
interesting open problem and with that
I'd like to thank you for attention
[Applause]
there's this n in the denominator of the
non-trivial learning algorithm at the
time right where does that come from
that factor event
all the
hypothesis
can you hear yeah
[Music]
um
it shouldn't be necessary
weakness so that you have
um the random functions are hard but you
don't really need the end there because
um
if you run a Time little of two to the
end you can't really
put a hypothesis that's
um
yeah this is just to give some slack in
this conversion
it's an actual property if you're more
careful about it
compared to the natural barriers
like constructing natural property right
but the famous barrier is very much you
may not have this property for like the
Chinese classes like this Carriage up on
the settings
that uh you mean the National Property
barrier yeah
I don't think it implies it but again I
think there's a bigger article so well
it depends on your highness assumptions
right like some of this prf
constructions they're based on classical
hardness activities
anyway just they're trying to figure out
actually the philosophical questions
I did
yeah yeah okay we're we have a more
possible way like oh like think about
the learning algorithms so it's about a
constructive thing and uh they need to
try to explore another structure and
achievement algorithms but indeed uh
this would imply like virus out the
device natural properties
and it didn't start and that's why I
don't know how to use it for any useful
thing so far but uh
foreign
the love is have said it by just
designing it from Financial approach but
you could use it somehow like some
extract level
foreign
so this is some uh some approach to
power forward yeah
yeah
very much